merci de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure Jérôme Durand on
vous êtes sénateur socialiste de
Saône-et-Loire vice-président de la
commission des lois on va longuement
parler de la loi locmin dont le Sénat
entame l'examen cet après-midi mais
d'abord vous l'avez vu évidemment la
pénurie de carburant un tiers des
stations-service du pays sont touchées
Isabelle borne a réuni hier soir
plusieurs ministres à Matignon réunion
d'urgence pour faire le point une
réunion mais pas de décision vous le
regrettez
on se demande ce qui se passe à la tête
de l'État en a le sentiment qu'on a un
gouvernement un président qui sont entre
hébétude et déni il y avait pas de super
profit pour Bruno Le Maire il n'y a pas
de pénurie pour les vieux vérans il y a
pas de difficultés dans la police avec
Gérald Darmanin et pas de difficulté
avec du pont Moretti à la justice
finalement sur le constat on a le
sentiment que le gouvernement est et ses
ministres porte de drôles de lunettes et
qu'il est temps un peu d'agir et la
réunion d'hier finalement à quoi
a-t-elle servi on sait pas très bien
vous attendez quelle décision de la part
du gouvernement est-ce que c'est au
gouvernement
ménagères sur ce sujet ou est-ce que
c'est des choses qui doivent cingler au
sein de l'entreprise au sein total en
l'occurrence total a réalisé 15
milliards de bénéfices son patron c'est
augmenter de 50%. ils ont versé 2,6
milliards d'euros de dividendes à leurs
actionnaires on nous explique qu'il y a
pas de super profit mais en même temps
vous venez d'annoncer qu'il y a un
amendement qui est déposé il faut juste
choisir une ligne un tout petit peu de
cohérence et l'assumer et quand il y a
un sentiment d'injustice c'est un moteur
extrêmement puissant de colère donc à la
colère elle alimentée par les inégalités
et c'est ce sujet-là qu'il faut traiter
il peut aller jusqu'où cette colère pour
vous bah écoutez moi je trouve que la
population est quand même about parce
que on vit une période qui est
inquiétante à bien des égards la
question du pouvoir d'achat elle est
déjà là et on a peur que ce soit pire
plus la pénurie d'essence ça finit par
faire beaucoup donc il faut s'en occuper
sérieusement pour redouter un mouvement
gilet jaune puissance
Cassandre ou les oiseaux de mauvaise
augure mais mais en tout cas on sent que
on sent qu'il y a une vraie tension dans
la société pour revenir à Total total
c'est le plus grand groupe pétrolier
français il y a pas de tissu pour le
moment pas de négociation et le total a
sorti pardon il y a un communiqué 10 ans
que le salaire moyen d'un opérateur de
raffinerie était de 5000 € mensuel
participation et intéressement compris
sont des chiffres qui sont contestés par
les syndicats mais est-ce que ce montant
justifie de tel blocage
je trouve que c'est un drôle de procédé
de crédibiliser discréditer des salariés
en grève la grève elle provoque une gêne
elle est le symptôme de quelque chose
c'est la douleur l'injustice à l'origine
de la greffe qu'il faut traiter plutôt
que d'essayer de la de la discréditer
vous le disiez le gouvernement a déposé
un amendement au budget qui prévoit de
créer une contribution temporaire de
solidarité c'est une sorte de taxe sur
les super profits mais qui ne dit pas
vraiment son nom vous le saluez cet
amendement c'est un peu tard on a vu le
sentiment que les super profits c'était
arrêté la porte du pays comme le nuage
de Tchernobyl à l'époque c'était un
sujet européen c'était un sujet français
puis finalement c'est un sujet français
il faudrait peut-être que on retrouve un
petit peu de niaque un peu de vitamines
pour que les choses soient vraiment
prises en main
on verra déjà ce qui arrivera chez nous
mais c'est moi prendre évidemment
qui prévoit plus de moyens pour les
forces de l'ordre on va voir ce que
contient précisément ce texte de loi
avec Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Ariane bonjour
la sécurité prévoit une hausse des
moyens pour les forces de l'ordre pour
les 5 prochaines années oui cette loi de
programmation elle sert d'abord à donner
de la visibilité sur les moyens des
forces de l'ordre pour le quinquennat à
venir et les moyens sont conséquents
avec 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dont une partie orientée
sur la lutte contre la cybercriminalité
et puis la création de 8500 postes de
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
dont 3000 pour l'an prochain l'objectif
à fixé par Emmanuel Macron c'est de
doubler la présence des forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain d'ici à 2030 une
présence qui pour l'instant est jugé
insuffisante écoutez le ministre de
l'Intérieur
nous voyons que notamment ces
indicateurs de violence fait aux
personnes continuellement et surtout
depuis le covid celle-ci augmente sans
doute par manque de présence de voie
publique des policiers et des gendarmes
et Alexandre débat aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle les sénateurs de la
commission des lois ont déjà porté des
modifications au texte mais oui les
modifications de la commission des lois
ça peut donner un ordre d'idées de la
position de la majorité de droite et du
centre au Sénat dans l'hémicycle à
partir d'aujourd'hui et ce qui a modifié
la commission des lois et bien ça
concerne les peines pour certaines
violences c'est-à-dire que les sénateurs
disent on est d'accord pour une hausse
des moyens mais il faut durcir et bien
certaines peines pour des violences
qu'on voit trop souvent dans l'actualité
on va écouter le rapporteur de ce projet
loi Mark Philippe dobress partir du
moment où vous mettez des moyens
supplémentaires sur la police et sur les
sur l'allègement des procédures il faut
que de manière serréophonique que vous
ayez une une concomitance pour qu'on ait
une procédure qui est enfin soit utile
c'est pour ça que j'ai présenté un
amendement qui sanctionne beaucoup plus
fort les violences faites aux élus plus
47% en un an les refus d'obtent tempérés
plus 17% en un an et les rodéo urbains
qui sont quand même le feuilleton du
quotidien que voit nos concitoyens et
d'abord pour les violences faites aux
élus les sénateurs proposent de durcir
la peine à 50 prisons et
75000 euros d'amende ensuite pour les
refus d'obtempérer face aux forces de
l'ordre et bien la peine proposé par la
Commission des lois peut aller jusqu'à 3
ans de prison et 30000 euros d'amende
durcissement pour les rodéo urbains à 50
prisons et 75000 € en amende sont
proposés par les sénateurs alors avec ce
projet de loi le gouvernement veut aussi
étendre l'amende forfaitaire qui
aujourd'hui en vigueur pour la
consommation de stupéfiants et bien le
gouvernement veut les tendre à tous les
délits passibles de moins d'un an de
prison les sénateurs en commission ont à
restreint le champ des délits concernés
par cette extension Jérôme Durin on va
évoquer le détail de cette loi mais
d'abord d'une manière générale est-ce
que les sénateurs socialistes vont voter
ce texte qui augmente les moyens des
forces de l'ordre on va débattre d'abord
on va défendre nos amendements puis on
verra qui sortira de cette lecture
puisque le vote solennelle n'intervient
que mardi prochain
en revanche il est évident que contester
des moyens nouveaux pour les forces de
sécurité intérieure ce serait malvenu
parce que la sécurité c'est un droit
c'est une demande de la population et
que c'est effectivement dans la période
que chose d'utile les crédits sont
utiles derrière il y a des mesures qui
sont plus nuancées les crédits sont
utiles ça veut dire qu'il y a une sorte
de division entre les socialistes et les
autres membres de l'Alliance de gauche
de la nu par exemple elle est communiste
les écologistes les insoumis qui sont
contre cette loi mais nous on n'a pas
vocation nous socialistes en tout cas au
Sénat à être contre par principe il y a
les textes sur la sécurité avec lesquels
on a été bien plus en désaccord je pense
à sécurité globale qui me reste
d'ailleurs toujours un peu à travers la
gorge sur certains aspects sur le
continuum de sécurité et je pense que ça
il faudra y revenir
qu'est-ce que la sécurité c'est une
prérogative régalienne oui ou non avec
le continuum de sécurité on a essayé de
nous faire croire il y a deux ans que
finalement tout le monde pouvait s'en
occuper un petit peu mais quand ça va
mal aujourd'hui sur le terrain je pense
à ce qui s'est passé à Nantes c'est
finalement mise à l'intérieur qui tense
les mères en leur disant vous faites mal
votre travail et la sécurité c'est le
travail de l'État donc là on n'est pas
d'accord sur le texte c'est plus
équilibré voilà donc la ligne est
socialiste sur cette ose et moyens c'est
d'être plutôt favorable alors la
commission des lois a durci certaines
peines pour des violences parlons
d'abord des violences faites aux élus il
faut durcir les peines pour ce type de
violence en particulier moi j'ai des
témoignages de terrain de maire de
collègues sénateurs qui traduisent une
une violence agrue au moins une
agressivité accrue donc que le régime
qui est impliqué aux élus soit aligné
sur d'autres dépositaires de l'autorité
publique me paraît normal en revanche
dans cette amendement
il y avait d'autres aspects avec
lesquels on est prêt vous allez soutenir
sur les élus et oui sur les Rodeo
urbains qui font chaque semaine le
feuilleton de l'actualité comme le
disait le rapporteur là est-ce qu'il
faut durcir les peines vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure ne durcissement par les
rapporteurs du texte c'est pas le cas il
y a cet amendement qui fasciemment est
un petit peu un petit peu sévère avec
ces trois points pour le reste c'est
beaucoup plus nuancé nous on est
d'accord pour les élus sur les rodéo et
sur le refus d'obtempérer surtout on
n'est pas d'accord les rodéo on y
revient tous les ans avec une efficacité
qui est quand même assez moyenne donc
non à ce stade on ne conteste pas la
réalité des difficultés mais ils ne sont
pas que ce soit la solution la solution
Charleroi en tout cas en tout cas dire
attention on va taper fort je pense que
c'est pas efficace et les refus
d'obtempérer il y a un problème beaucoup
plus profond qui tient à la doctrine
d'emploi des armes par les forces de
l'ordre et qui posent problème puisque
l'occasion de le dire ici il y a des
vies humaines qui sont gâchées et donc
il faut quand même qu'on se pose sur le
sur la question ça veut dire que les
policiers
usent on va pouvoir trop élargi
quelque chose qui disent oui oui parce
que chaque fois qu'on parle des
questions de police on nous parle de la
chaîne [__] donc ça ne peut pas
fonctionner seulement du côté police
parce que si on donne des moyens à la
police alors on se retournera vers la
justice en disant vous voyez bien la
justice est inefficace et c'est assez
injuste pour le coup il faut donc
travailler des deux concerts dès le côté
c'est effectivement
pour simplifier un peu le travail de la
justice et ce qu'il faut étendre
l'amende forfaitaire délictuelle à tous
les petits délits passibles de moins
d'un an de prison comme le propose le
gouvernement non non d'ailleurs les
rapporteurs eux-mêmes ont choisi de
restreindre l'usage de cet amende
forfaitaire déluelle il y en a 200 000
par an elles sont utilisées aujourd'hui
plutôt pour les questions stupéfiantes
et les questions routières ça se passe
quand même sans le contrôle du juge il y
a un risque d'arbitraire donc faut faire
très attention avec ça tellement de
forfaits délictuel nous on a un
amendement de principe de refus de
l'extension on verra comment les débats
se passent
et je pense qu'il faut faire attention
ça peut être un outil mais vraiment à
manier avec précaution il peut y avoir
certaines dérives bien sûr par exemple
s'il s'agit d'un outrage à agence si
c'est l'agent lui-même qui délivre
l'amende forfaitaire déluelle vous voyez
bien qu'il y a un conflit d'intérêt et
qui a un risque d'arbitraire évident si
c'est les tags dans les Hauts d'immeuble
on voit les difficultés que ça peut
générer donc voilà il faut être
précautionneux vous avez publié vous
avez passé pardon plus de 30 amendements
sur ce texte sur quel autre point vous
souhaitez le modifier ce texte nous
refus d'obtempérer évidemment à monter
intellectuel j'en ai parlé on a des
réserves surtout ce qui concerne
l'investigation la filière investigation
la formation des officiers police
judiciaires les assistants police
judiciaires les fameux greffiers de
police tels qu'ils ont failli s'appeler
et puis on a un travail assez important
qui a été construit par nos collègues
sur tout le volet violence
intrafamiliale outrage sexiste ou
violence sexuelle voilà donc c'est des
sujets qui me tiennent vraiment à coeur
et pour lesquels on pense qu'on peut
utilement apporter à la loi on va en
parler dans le club dans une demi-heure
mais c'est aussi un texte qui crée des
brigades de gendarmerie en milieu rural
ça c'est une bonne chose c'est bien venu
le la délinquance a évolué c'est déplacé
des grands centres urbains vers les
villes moyennes vers les petites villes
vers les campagnes il y a la question
des stupéfiants il y a évidemment très
profondément ancré dans la dans la vie
de nos concitoyens les violences
intrafamiliales qui sont accrues avec le
covid le confinement donc qu'on est des
forces de sécurité en territoire rural
est une très bonne chose et on en
parlera tout à l'heure avec vous Alex en
fait effectivement rien dans le club
dans une demi-heure on parlera de ce
sujet à délinquance en milieu rural
merci Alex à tout à l'heure on va parler
d'une réforme controversée celle de la
police judiciaire portée par Gérald
Darmanin là aussi elle prévoit de placer
tous les services de police
renseignement sécurité publique police
aux frontières et PJ sous l'autorité
d'un seul directeur départemental
dépendant du préfet c'est une réforme
qui crée des remous notamment du côté de
Marseille on retrouve Guilhem riccavi
bonjour Guilhem merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur des rédactions de la
Provence Guilhem et on va revenir avec
vous sur la grogne la colère des
policiers marseillais qui aboutit au
limoge du directeur de la piscine de
Marseille
oui effectivement une grogne qui a été
intense et qui a même d'ailleurs
largement dépassé Marseille puisque dans
de très nombreux commissariats de France
on a pu voir vendredi après-midi et
samedi et bien des mobilisations
d'enquêteurs justement contre le
limogeage d'Eric Arella et ericarella
qui est donc un patron respecté de la PJ
de Marseille qui était en tout cas un
patron respecté puisque au lendemain
d'une mobilisation de ses officiers
contre la réforme et bien il a été
démine ses fonctions il a payé au prix
cher j'allais dire le fait que ces
hommes ne partagent pas cette envie de
réforme et donc cette mobilisation c'est
poursuivi vendredi après-midi avec une
haie d'honneur qui lui a été faite à sa
sortie de l'évêché le siège de la police
judiciaire à Marseille qui s'est
prolongé samedi dimanche et hier encore
à la PJ de Marseille les affaires
tournent au ralenti pour montrer la
désapprobation totale après ce limogeage
un petit peu surprenant
un mot là-dessus genre la question de
Guilhem sur c'est l'image du directeur
de la PJ de Marseille c'est une erreur
pour vous oui c'est une erreur c'est une
erreur mais comme cette réforme de la PJ
itinéraire c'est une erreur sur le fond
puisque ce sont des gens qui s'occupent
de faire de criminalité organisée
criminalité complexe qui ont besoin de
temps et ont finalement on risque de les
affecter à la délinquance du quotidien
de leur faire faire autre chose que ce
qu'il sait faire une question pour vous
là
oui justement comment est-ce qu'on
apporte selon vous une réponse notamment
à Marseille où on voit bien cette
criminalité organisée comment est-ce
qu'on fait dès lors que cette réforme
sera mise en place à l'horizon 2023
est-ce qu'on ne va pas perdre cette
spécificité de la police judiciaire pour
affronter ces trafics de stupéfiants par
exemple si moi je pense que que la
question telle que vous la posez et bien
posée on risque avec la réforme de
perdre des vrais pros de l'enquête au
fond sur le temps long et la pression du
quotidien pour la petite et moyenne
délinquance elle finira à s'imposer et
tôt ou tard les ddpn les fameux
directeurs départementaux de la police
nationale finiront par dire aux
enquêteurs de la PJ bon les gars je sais
que vous avez des trucs sur le feu mais
là l'urgence c'est c'est la petite
criminalité donc c'est une mauvaise idée
on sait qu'il y a une désinfections pour
l'investigation pour la filière
investigation pour la police judiciaire
manque de moyens mais c'est précisément
parce qu'on manque de moyens qu'il faut
pas utiliser ses compétences qui sont
trop rares pour aller les mettre dans un
pot commun ou finalement c'est bon
professionnel seront utilisé à autre
chose que l'investigation que le travail
au long cours et puis elle risque
politique quand François Melun quand les
procureurs conférence des procureurs
l'Union Syndicale des Magistrats la
conférence des barreaux procureur de
Paris disent qu'ils sont inquiets de
cette réforme c'est quand même qui a une
forme d'entêtement chez le ministre de
l'Intérieur à vouloir persévérer chez
lui chez le directeur de la police
nationale et on comprend pas bien
pourquoi on en arrive à cette extrémité
ou Bordeaux Rennes Toulouse Angers sont
aujourd'hui dans le refus d'opérer les
opérations du quotidien c'est quand même
rare dans la police puisque vous parlez
de la justice vous étonnez du silence
des règles du pont Moretti sur ce sujet
d'un côté qui peut parler sur contre une
réforme défendue par Gérald Darmanin il
y a eu une des séances du beau de la
sécurité qui est intéressante j'ai
assisté pour le Sénat où on avait Éric
Dupont-Moretti et Gérald Darmanin qui
l'invitait je crois effectivement que on
travaille pas suffisamment main dans la
main entre l'intérieur et la justice et
chaque fois on se renvoie la patate
chaude
plus exactement on accable la justice
sont incompétence c'est un peu ce qui
renvoyait le message général alors même
qu'il y a une chaîne d'ailleurs on parle
de chaîne police justice de chaîne
pénale et je pense qu'effectivement il
faudrait travailler de concert alors
peut-être que
Eric Dupond-Moretti a d'autres
actualités qui
retiennent son attention mais mais je
pense d'exercer correctement sa mission
pour vous non mais je pense que le on
aurait aimé effectivement que tout ça
soit mieux piloté mais ça renvoie ce
qu'on se disait tout à l'heure en début
d'entretien il y a quand même un
sentiment de flou dans la période dans
la gestion des affaires du pays
géraldman il a défendu évidemment sa
réforme hier dans le Parisien mais il
semble fléchir légèrement sur la date il
parle maintenant d'un second semestre
2023 alors qu'avant il disait courant
2023 c'est un premier pas pour vous oui
envoyer un courrier hier qui qui prend
cet élément de calendrier
il commence à envisager une forme de
négociation mieux vaut tard que moi-même
et c'est quand même un peu tard Guilhem
un dernier mot ou votre une comme vous
voulez Mylène
oui effectivement dans notre une on
revient longuement sur les pénuries
d'essence qui frappent durement
Marseille il est quasiment impossible de
trouver aujourd'hui de l'essence à
Marseille aux abords proches et en
assiste à des fils à des queues in
interrompu dans les rares stations près
d'un kilomètre de file d'attente à la
station Total sur l'ère de la pomme sur
la 50 en direction d'Aubagne la
problématique est désormais réelle dans
la deuxième ville de France en matière
d'approvisionnement merci beaucoup
Guilhem merci alors que Olivier Vérand
qui parle sur RTL à l'instant dit qui
est le gouvernement se réserve la
possibilité d'intervenir pour lever ces
blocages merci beaucoup Guilhem d'avoir
été avec nous on va parler de
l'actualité politique du parti
socialiste de la nuque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon d'abord il a réaffirmé
dimanche vous l'avez sans doute entendu
son soutien à Adrien cattenin s'il parle
de gifle politique qui lui sont donnés
dans les médias matin midi et soir
est-ce que vous cautionnez ce type de
propos je pense que c'est à tous les
mois maladroit et inopportun
il aurait pas dû c'est une erreur
politique pour vous
ne pas sentir que
le climat politique les principes
les attentes de la population sont sur
une forme de de plus grande rigueur et
sans doute une faute politique et je
pense qu'il faut passer à autre chose il
devient un allié encombrant Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour la nuque en tout cas sur
cette sur ces prises de position je
pense que on peut pas le suivre
évidemment et puis
je renvoie à ce que disait François
Ruffin ces jours-ci qui dit que il s'est
rendu compte que hurler sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée n'était pas efficace je le
pense aussi et fait le jeu du
rassemblement national
je me sens humiliée par le spectacle
donné par la nuque c'est ce qu'a dit ce
week-end François Hollande il était dans
les Alpes-Maritimes qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette phrase
je pense qu'il faut être soit sur le
terrain soit en tribune mais on peut pas
faire les deux
voilà c'est un chien Président je pense
que ça réveille beaucoup d'amertume et
c'est pas des obligeant de le dire mais
ça renvoie à la fin du quinquennat ça
renvoie l'impossibilité à se représenter
voilà donc si on peut s'épargner ce type
de commentaires c'est aussi bien ça veut
dire qu'il devrait tourner la page il
devrait plus intervenir dans les
affaires du Parti socialiste pour vous
François Hollande
après la ligne choisie par Oliver
[Musique]
le sujet quel est-il pour la gauche
c'est de reconquérir les classes
populaires on parlait à l'instant de
Ruffin de ce qui fait les affaires du
rassemblement national la petite musique
qu'on entend dans le débat public c'est
comment empêcher le RN désormais d'être
au pouvoir en 2027 donc on peut
continuer comme à l'époque où nous
étions majoritaire nous étions très
puissants à avoir des petites phrases
des commentaires je crois que c'est
intéressant que ce n'est pas alors c'est
une période de congrès mais que ce n'est
pas fructue fructueux que ça ne produit
rien politiquement et que en tout cas ça
ne touche pas le cœur de ce dont on
voudrait qu'il vote pour nous ok il faut
qu'on soit plus plus direct qu'on
apporte des réponses qu'on soit dans le
registre des solutions et les petites
phrases de ce type là me semble-t-il ne
sert à rien
il y a dix jours 154 du Parti socialiste
appelé via une tribune dans Le Journal
du Dimanche à une troisième voie entre
la ligne pro Nupe défendue par Olivier
Faure et la ligne continue qui est aussi
au sein du PS parmi les signataires il y
a votre président de groupe ici au Sénat
Patrick Canada vous êtes d'accord avec
cet appel moi je vais pas signer moi
maligne dans ce congrès ce sera
celle de d'une gauche qui renoue avec
les classes populaires donc on connaît
ses premiers appels ces tribunes qui
sont sur le fond encore assez générique
on va dire comme ça comme ça et mon
engagement moi ira vers la ligne qui qui
nous permettra de nous rapprocher des
classes populaires et c'est la ligne
d'Olivier fort on verra en tout cas moi
ce que je peux dire sur la nuque pro ou
antiforce c'est que je suis quand même
heureux et ça fait écho au débat
précédent que grâce à la nuque on est
retrouvé notre place dans la gauche
donc c'est un acquis alors maintenant
est-ce qu'il faut continuer dans la Nupe
de la même façon la politique ça se
construit tous les jours les
circonstances nous font évoluer on fait
des choix et puis on est obligé de
changer donc ça ça n'est pas choquant
mais en revanche il faut prendre les
choses telles qu'elles sont on était
discréditées aux parties socialiste
après 2017 nous avons enfanté Emmanuel
Macron sur une ligne politique n'était
pas une ligne de gauche qui était pas
celle de la lutte contre l'ennemi qui
était la finance on a été
en question
le passage de dans la Nupe cet accord
avec le reste de la gauche nous a reçu
dans la gauche donc il faut faire
fructifier ça et il faut trouver une
ligne qui maintenant nous permettent de
gagner le coeur des classes populaires
et d'avoir une offre qui est majoritaire
alors est-ce que c'est cette troisième
voie est-ce que c'est Olivier fort on
entre dans le Congrès il y a beaucoup de
tumulte au début beaucoup d'écume une
fois que la poussière retombera on verra
quelle est la ligne politique qui est la
plus efficace en tout cas c'est comme ça
que je me positionnerai et pour les
sénatoriales puisque ça arrive c'est
dans moins d'un an maintenant est-ce que
il faut une des accords avec la nuque ou
est-ce que là le PS qui est majoritaire
pour le coup dans les territoires doit
s'affirmer écoute moi je pense que pour
les sénatoriales on a un personnel
politique qui est puissant qui est
présent dans les territoires on a une
vraie richesse dans la gestion des
collectivités locales avec des élus qui
sont compétents qu'ils ont expérimenté
et on a tout ce qu'il faut pour avoir un
bon groupe après le renouvellement
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin dans 20 minutes dans lequel
territoire on ira en Mayenne ou Emmanuel
Macron s'est rendu hier pour parler des
centralisations et des fentes dit-il une
vraie décentralisation on verra tout ça
tout à